is the best time of the year to get your
carpets clean so ben mckee of zerorez
joins us to share how carpet
professionally cleaned can have you and
your family enjoying a cleaner and
healthier home while escaping that
summer heat so ben
why why do you think summer is the best
time in your opinion welcome back guys
by the way oh it's good to be here well
it's summertime you know our kids are
out of school finally it's time to get
our houses cleaned up right um back to
like new condition and there's no better
way to do that than by getting your
carpets professionally cleaned freshness
right yeah bring the freshness in you
know it's we've got the heat it's it's
hot let's just get your carpets cleaned
up and looking good right and when you
you know during the summer we're trying
to escape the heat like i said you have
people coming over to your house looking
at what we're seeing on the floor right
now that would be embarrassing it will
be
so don't don't be the shame of the
neighborhood get your get your carpets
clean and we're gonna do it in the most
like technologically advanced process
ever at zero rez we clean with science
rather than just like focus focus stuff
we're using patented technology it
leaves your carpets cleaner than any
other cleaning uh
compound out there right and the best
part is it dries soft to the touch like
it just came from the factory okay well
with that said it's time to see what the
you said no hocus pocus but i have to
say this is also magic okay it is
magical
it is also magic so what what's
happening right now so we got this
hooked up to our truck mount that's
parked outside imagine not having a 300
horsepower vacuum
this water we call it zr water okay it's
what our patented technology is based on
it is heated up to near 230 degrees at
the truck
so we're able to clean it through the
grease the grime the dirt whatever
you've got and the best part is
even though we're cleaning and it's it's
wet it's damp to the touch it's not
soaking wet touch it
it's nearly dry see wow okay okay and
also with that you know this is really
good for allergies too because
everybody's dealing with that right now
especially seasonally yeah it's your
carpet's actually the biggest air filter
at your home or at your business so by
getting it professionally cleaned you
can get that that air filter reset so it
can go back to doing its job of
filtering out dander pollen dust you
name it it's getting trapped in your
carpets also filtering out pet hair and
grime so let's talk about what you guys
do when owners have pets at home i know
it's summer time so if you got a pet at
home you're probably smelling your spots
right now
it's getting hot and so those smells
seem to come out a little bit more we
have an arsenal of products that can
safely and effectively go after the
stain and the odor that's caused by our
beautiful furby i know we love them but
they can sink sometimes and it's a
permanent solution right it is so i mean
we can go after and address the smell
and the odor and you can have your home
back to like new almost okay well that
sounds wonderful and you know not to
toot your horn but you guys have rave
reviews online and also you've won best
of las vegas for the fourth year four
four years in a row okay why do you
think that is you know so if you go
check us out on google yeah and not a
lot of companies will tell you to go do
that because they might be embarrassed
about the reviews but we have over 6 000
reviews with a 4.9 star average here in
las vegas and we've gotten there because
we train our technicians every single
day when they come into the office we
have a dedicated call center that works
with us locally here in las vegas
they're in our office they're our
employees so they're trained properly to
provide the best customer experience
possible there we go best customer
experience and best product look at that
look at that you guys get your homes
ready all right give zero res a call at
702-840-3333
per room plus receive free tile cleaning
of 100 square feet
that is great thank you guys hey thanks
rocky